we've been working with bigquery  recently to replace our existing data  and analytics of the structure asada's  been able to help us get the information  we need or answer the questions that  we've had about google bot platform this  was a big decision for us while it's  great that gcp makes things easy enough  that we can get there on our own for the  most part it's great to have a partner  like sada that we can call at any time  to help us get the rest of the way the  reason that said exes likes Google cloud  platform and bigquery in particular so  much is because it makes things so easy  for us as far as analytics scope we've  had people dedicated full time to  supporting our old analytics platform  and now those people can work on more  interesting things than doing operations  support for relational database  operating in the cloud is difficult it's  nice to have good partners it's nice to  have a great platform to work on sod on  gcp make that possible  you  [Music]